what does his moose fights back what is  this oh yeah we've seen this yeah the  two fight the I don't think I've seen  this the two me's bucking geez Louise  get out of my [ __ ] truck I thought  that was in the video for a second hey  y'all take that horse play over there  baby knock it off get away from my truck  dad those ain't horses those is me's get  that Meats play away from the car do the  sound of the horns locking in yeah that  was brutal yeah you know I feel bad for  people to just listening how much you  want to bet these moose eat wild  mushrooms and are just tripping balls or  they run out into the [ __ ] road yeah  probably that's what I run right at the  car yeah like Valhalla